لاعبوا السيتي ابطال من امام شاشات
التلفاز قميص برشلونه بمنزل رونالدو في
السعوديه وما هو رد مدافعي فانر بخشا على
واقعه بصقه على التريزيجيه هذه الاخبار
وغيرها ننقلها لكم عبر قناه العربيه رياضه
اسعدوا بمتابعتكم
نبدا اخبارنا لهذا اليوم مع التفاعل الذي
شهدته مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بتتويج
مانشستر سيتي بلقب البريميرليج بينما كان
لاعبه وجهازهم الفني مجتمعين امام شاشه
التلفاز لمتابعه خساره ارسنال امام
نوتنجهام يعد سيتي تفاعلوا على السوشيال
ميديا وشاركوا جماهيرهم فرحه اللقب حالا
تحديدا لفت الانظار باستخدامه اللغه
الفرنسيه في منشوره كاتبا سيموسيتي في
مواضع على بورد 5 كؤوس فوق صورته في اشاره
منه لللقب الخامس لسيتي في السنوات السته
والى الفيديو الذي نشرته جورجينا رودريغيز
صديقه البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو عبر
حسابها على الانستغرام يظهر فيه ابنه
ماتيو برشلونه وبرفقه شقيقه ايفا واخته
الانا مارتينا وهما يوغنون على الكنبه في
غرفه المعيشه جورجينا ارفقت الشريط
بايموجي على شكل قلب وايموجي اخر ضاحك
فكتبت منشن لكريستيانو رونالدو ولم يعرف
بعد رده فعل والده لاعب النصر السعودي ولا
حتى سبب قيام جورجينا بشعل طفلها الصغير
يرتدي قميص النادي الكتلوني يوم تتويجه
بلقب الدوري الاسباني
الختام مع مقتل 12 شخصا وجرح المئات في
السلفادور جراء تدافعي مشجعينا حاولوا
دخول ملعب في العاصمه
مباراه كره قدم في الدوري المحلي جمعت بين
فريقين الياسا وسيدي فاس حسبما اعلنت
الشرطه المحليه التدافع ادى الى اصابه
اكثر من 500 شخص داخل الملعب ونقل اكثر من
مئه شخص في حاله حرجه الى المستشفيات
القريبه والمرافق الصحيه